صحفي صادر عن بلديه غزه غزه امام كارثه
انسانيه محققه في ظل استمرار العدوان
الاسرائيلي مع استمرار هذا العدوان على
قطاع غزه لليوم الخامس بعد المئه وجريمه
الاباده الجماعيه بحق ابناء شعبنا من
المدنيين العزل وقتل الاف المدنيين وجح
عشرات الالاف وتدمير كبير في المباني
والمنشات المدنيه والمرافق والخدمات
والبنيه التحتيه وتجريف الحدائق العامه
والاشجار وقطع المياه والكهرباء ومنع وصول
الطعام للمدنيين ومنع الوقود اللازم
لتشغيل الاليات والمرافق الخدمات وتحويل
غزه الى مدينه
منكوبه كل هذا انعكس بشكل كبير وخطير على
تقديم الخدمات الانسانيه التي تقدمها
البلديه والتي يكفلها القانون الدولي
الانساني تحاول البلديه جاهده منذ بدء
العدوان لتوفير الخدمات الانسانيه من
المياه وجمع وترحيل النفايات وتصريف
المياه العادمه ومياه الامطار ولكن بسبب
نفاد الوقود وتدمير المرافق الخدماتي
كابار المياه ومحطات الصرف الصحي والاليات
وتدمير عدد كبير من مولدات الكهرباء ادى
هذا الى حاله شلل شبه تام مما شكل خطوره
كبيره على حياه المدنيين وبناء على هذا
تؤكد بلديه غزه على ما يلي ان استمرار
العدوان وازمه نفاد الوقود يشكلان تحديا
كبيرا امام البلديه لتوفير الخدمات
الاساسيه الاساسيه
للمواطنين ويزيد من حجم الكارثه الصحيه
والبيئيه في المدينه ويشكل خطوره كبيره
على حياه المواطنين من حيث انتشار الامراض
المعديه
والاوبئه تؤكد بلديه غزه ان تراكم كميات
كبيره من النفايات امام المستشفيات ومراكز
الايواء وفي الشوارع والكبات
العشوائيه بكميه تزيد عن 50,000 طن بما
فيها النفايات الطبيه الخطره وطفح الصرف
الصحي في الشوارع وعلى شاطئ البحر ونقص
المياه بشكل كبير ينذر بانتشار العديد من
الامراض والاوبئه الخطيره والتي يصعب
علاجها ان لم يتم تدارك الامور بسرعه
كبيره تحذر بلديه غزه من خطوره الاوضاع في
بركه تجميع مياه الامطار في حي الشيخ
رضوان بشكل خاص وان مستوى البركه وصل الى
نقطه حرجه وخطيره كما تم تدمير مولدات
الكهرباء والمرافق والاسوار في البركه مما
زاد من المشكله وقد يؤدي تساقط كميات
اضافيه من مياه الامطار مع استمرار تسريب
مياه الصرف الصحي اليها الى فيضان البركه
وغرق المناطق المحيطه بها مما يتسبب في
تلوث للمخزون الجوفي وبالتالي انتشار جديد
للامراض الخطيره والاوبئه في صفوف
المواطنين تطالب بلديه غزه المجتمع الدولي
ومنظمات حقوق الانسان وجميع الاحرار
بالعالم للتدخل العاجل وتوفير الوقود
مولدات الكهرباء والاليات والمركبات
والمعدات لتامين وصول الخدمات الاساسيه
للمواطنين والتقليم من حجم الكارثه
والتقليل من حاله العطش الشديد التي
تشهدها المدينه ويعاني منها المواطنون
يؤكد بلديه غزه استمرارها بالعمل والوقوف
الى جانب ابناء شعبنا وبذل الجهود لتوفير
الخدمات الاساسيه وذلك بما يتوفر لديها من
امكانيات ولازالت هذه الامكانيات محدوده
[موسيقى]
جدا gaz